рихіто безвізового режиму з України та
низько сови увійти каченя через про мальний
референдуму нідерландах та й допоможе угма
а ти не захворів написати число не
ЗМІ і дайте українці, що продають, країни
євросоюзом а то мульт про вузу провід
живуть цим годинний візовий режим з
україною настрибнуть на жаль катування ризик про
зростанні кільку стиме карантин
експерт виявиться і звучна практика ви
підкосами тушею масштабні пуде інок
штат чемпіонат us with us футболу
завжди можна буде за дроти tight їм
годинний контроль на кордоні
механізмами сором йому з його vadis
ukranian та та вухами аналогічні норми та
шенгенські угіддя он і дозволяти краю
нам членами це за провід живота
контроль але нам вдалий кордонах і
мета завербувався у майстерно пловому
біженців у config.sys україни ціна лікарі
повторі в цьому і тебе обожнюють експерти
не моя жадібних у знак того, що в роті
відсіку вати напливу посмішку та кіль кістка
україни телику нам про це і типу стежки
ти до Європи
лібералізації візового режиму призначаєш
ніж мільйони людей загрозу завищувати краї
ну там пак ще є завжди мій чоловік
новин змін це закон зручності
безвізовий режим на передачу
автоматичного надання українцям право
на роботу в з Еньші деталлю роки поки
але розвалу суть купа проти ти на дно і
вже майже завершив і голова не
єврокомісії юнкера волосся вибір з них
чопра позицію україні за рублі найтіснішим
quit не
після цього пропозиції єврокомісії маус
хвалите кваліфікації набилися crying
числа не vs атаку сертифікати та
європарламент